my name is akia a new path e and my
major is an electrical engineering and
computer science my project is on
robustness of neural networks neural
networks have become increasingly
popular for a variety of tasks most
notably for image classification
unfortunately they're susceptible to
adversarial attacks this is one the
input to our neural network is slightly
perturbed in order to cause a Mis
classification this has serious
implications in applications like
self-driving cars for instance where
adversaries could cause accidents
fortunately we can find regions in the
input space that are certified to be
robust to perturbations so for example
in this image this ostrich if perturbed
will still be classified as an ostrich
within these green regions this raises
the question how do we efficiently train
neural networks to have these large
regions of certified robustness our
approach is to use two margins to
quantify the uncertainties in the
network at each layer one margin tracks
a level of linear uncertainty while
another margin tracks a level of
non-linearity these two margins can then
be used to approximate an upper bound on
the worst-case performance of the
network or the worst case adversarial
loss here we show our current results on
the y-axis we have certified accuracies
which are essentially the fraction of
points in a test set that we can show or
prove to be robust to adversaries of a
certain size on the x-axis we show the
assumed adversarial attack size the red
dotted line shows the current
state-of-the-art certified robust
training method while the blue solid
line shows our method as illustrated for
large perturbation sizes we can achieve
higher certified accuracy bounds
compared to the current state-of-the-art
in addition our method only takes three
times the training time of conventional
training which is on par with the
current state of art in terms of
training time next we hope to scale this
method to larger networks and larger
datasets